From movies to TV, This year has already delivered
a ton of creepy creatures that obviously come
from the most deviously creative minds in
the biz.
And after seeing these menacing things come
to life on-screen, it's probably a safe bet
that most of us will be losing an unusual
amount of sleep this year as well.
Here are a few of the scariest new monsters
of 2017.
Winslow on The Walking Dead
The Walking Dead's seventh season presented
Jadis and her community, a group of people
who've relied on garbage to create giant walls
to keep themselves safe.
That in and of itself was weird enough, but
then their pet zombie, Winslow, came into
the picture.
That's a special moment for small-screen scare
history.
Rick, who wanted to gain the favor of Jadis'
crew for his impending battle with Negan,
was thrown into a pit with the spiked, undead
beast and had to find a way to penetrate his
dangerous helmet to save his own skin.
Trouble was, he was decked out with knives
and a helmet reinforced with metal from a
gas tank.
So, not only did we find out just how much
Jadis doesn't play around when it comes to
protecting her junkyard life, but we also
got to see just how much of a resourceful
survivor Rick Grimes really is with his back
against the wall.
Or, you know, the garbage.
Pennywise from IT
Kids of the '80s and '90s who watched the
first iteration of Stephen King's IT will
no doubt recall the eerie, sickening feeling
that washed over them whenever Tim Curry’s
Pennywise the Clown arrived to torture the
children of Derry.
And it looks like this year's revival effort
will be just as terrifying, if the first glimpses
of the sinister cinematic clown are any indication.
Unlike Curry's version, there appears to be
less surface humor present in the new Pennywise,
played by Bill Skarsgard.
What's really going to earn prime placement
in people's' nightmares with this one, though,
is how grimy this Pennywise seems to be compared
to the last one.
Plus, there's the return of the red balloon
— that image alone is enough to induce a
shudder from an entire generation of horror
fans.
Kong: Skull Island’s lizard monster
Three tongues, countless teeth, and a grunt-scream
that sounds like a velociraptor?
That's a recipe for absolute disaster.
Kong: Skull Island's resident Skullcrawlers
gave new meaning to the concept of an ancient
apex predator, as only one mega-gorilla could
survive their systematic slaughter of his
species: King Kong.
It's basically the equivalent of what would
happen if the Cloverfield monster mated with
that real-life dino-sized croc that's been
haunting South Carolina golfers this year.
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2’s octo-beast
Thanks to movies like Pirates of the Caribbean:
Dead Man's Chest and Clash of the Titans,
we've certainly encountered our fair share
of Kraken-like beasts in movies past.
But what Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 pulled
off is something particularly awful.
The gang goes toe to toe with this toothy
space octopus monstrosity.
And Drax does it with just a pair of daggers.
That's a fight fit for a Destroyer, right?
As he leaps in to take on the tentacled creature,
yet another layer of gums open up to receive
him and it's a just whole 'nother level of
nope.
Calvin from Life
When are our fictional friends gonna just
learn that you can't go playing with alien
life-forms and expect things to go well for
anyone involved?
Like a lot of outer space thrillers, when
these International Space Station astronauts
actually discover Martian life, things are
not what they seem.
What begins as a cute little shimmying blob
turns into a full-on intergalactic nightmare
for everyone onboard, with a creature named
Calvin who can think, feed on almost anything,
and wants to instinctively destroy for the
sake of its own growth.
Unlike a lot of on-screen aliens, there's
nothing ridiculous or anthropomorphic about
this thing.
It's just plain horrible in a very believable
way.
Ahmanet from The Mummy
For those who remain skeptical about the Tom
Cruise-led reboot of The Mummy franchise,
we've got two words for you: Sofia Boutella.
The up-and-coming actress portrays an ancient
Egyptian princess named Ahmanet who was entombed
2,000 years ago after murdering her king-father,
then is accidentally resurrected into a power-hungry
world-wanderer who has no bones about being
an evil empress of darkness.
Not only does she have the power to revive
humans to do her deadly bidding, but she's
also pretty terrible to look at.
She's got some spooky eye-split maneuver that's
just bound to strike a nerve with anyone who
uses their own, single-irised eyes to see
it.
Alien: Covenant xenomorphs
With Alien: Covenant, Ridley Scott is returning
to form with his aliens that have tormented
audiences for decades.
The footage from this movie hearkens back
to imagery we've seen of these species before.
But there's also some menacing new material
at play, too.
And here we thought the chest-burster from
the original film was peak petrification.
But, this looks pretty good, too.
Man, talk about a bug on the windshield.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!